the 74th annual Academy Awards on ABC
brought to you by JCPenney celebrating
100 years of timeless values it's all
inside MasterCard there are some things
money can't buy for everything else
there's MasterCard and Beachwood a
Budweiser with the crisp clean and
refreshing taste known only to the king
of beers
a few weeks ago the Academy gathered for
its annual scientific and technical
awards dinner hosted by the gorgeous
Charlize Theron who offered the winners
this highly technical advice you don't
want to kiss me during the evening xx
for technical achievement scientific and
engineering awards and awards of
commendation were bestowed the gala was
kept with the Gordon East Sawyer award
presented to Edmund and D Julia my
sincere thanks to the Board of Governors
and the side Tech Committee for
bestowing on me this incredible honor
I accepted most humbly and gratefully it
is without a doubt the highlight of my
career
thanks to all of you for making this
fabulous night possible thanks a lot
in recognition of their steadily growing
importance in the motion picture arts
the Academy has added a new category
this year honoring animated feature
films Bambi who is now but Bambi who is
now in an assisted living facility in
Palm Springs has been lobbying for this
for years
I the man the meerkat the Nathan Lane
good evening I'm Greta Van Susteren I've
had a lot more work done
oh yes beneath this lovely tuxedo I'm
wearing the Victoria's Secret bra with
the 22 diamonds sewn in the lining
that's Hollywood for your real diamonds
fake breasts but it's great to be back
in the panic room
at long last an Academy Award for the
Best Animated Feature Film I know dear
old Walt Disney would be smiling right
now if he wasn't frozen solid you know